both you and
and uh elon think that with ai
you're so many demons summoning a demon
maybe not in those poetic terms but
well potent potentially potentially two
very
three very parsimonious assumptions
i think here scientifically parsimony's
assumptions
get me there um
any of which could be wrong but it just
it seems like the the weight of the
the evidence is on their side one is
that it comes back to this
topic of of substrate independence right
anyone who's in the business of
producing intelligent machines must
believe ultimately that
there's nothing magical about having a
computer made of meat you can do this
in the kinds of you know materials where
we're using
now and uh there's no special
something that's good that that presents
a a real impediment to producing
human level intelligence in silico right
again an assumption either i'm sure
there are a few people who still think
there is something magical about
you know biological systems but um
leave that aside
given that assumption and given the
assumption that we
just continue making incremental
progress doesn't have to be moore's law
it just has to be progress that just
doesn't stop
at a certain point we'll get to the
to human level intelligence and beyond
and human level intelligence
i think is also clearly a mirage because
anything that's human level
is going to be superhuman by unless we
decide to dumb it down right i mean
my phone is already superhuman as a
calculator right so why would we make
the human level ai you know just as good
as me a
as a calculator so i think we'll we'll
very
if we continue to make progress we will
be in the presence of
superhuman competence for any
act of intelligence or cognition
that we care to prioritize it's not to
say that we're we
will create everything that a human
could do maybe we'll leave certain
things out
but anything that we care about and we
care about a lot
and we certainly care about anything
that that produces a lot of
power you know that we care about
scientific insights and
and inability to produce new technology
and all of that
will have something that's superhuman
and then that
the final assumption is just that
there have to be ways to do that
that are not aligned with a happy
coexistence
with these now more powerful
entities than ourselves so and and i
would
i would guess and this is a you know
kind of a writer to that assumption
there are probably more ways to do it
badly than to do it
perfectly that is perfectly aligned
with our well-being and
when you think about the consequences of
of non-alignment
when you think about you're now in the
presence of something
that is more intelligent than you are
right which is to say more competent
right unless you've and and obviously
there are cartoon
pictures of this where we could just you
know this is just an off switch we could
just turn off the off switch or they're
tethered to something that that
makes them you know our slaves in
perpetuity even though they're more
intelligent but
that that strike those scenarios strike
me as a failure to imagine
what is actually entailed by greater
intelligence right so if you imagine
something that's
legitimately more intelligent than you
are
and you're now in relationship to it
right
you're in the presence of this thing and
it is autonomous in all kinds of ways
because it had to be to be more
intelligent than you are and you built
it to be
to be all of those things
we just can't find ourselves in a
negotiation
with something more intelligent than we
are you know and we can't er so
we have to have found the the the subset
of ways to build this
these machines that are that are
perpetually amenable to are saying
oh that's not what we meant that's not
what we intended could you stop doing
that
come back over here and do this thing
that we actually want
and for them to care for them to be
tethered to our own sense of our own
well-being
such that you know i mean their utility
function
is you know their their primary utility
function is for is to have you know this
is
i think stuart russell's uh
you know cartoon uh
plan is to figure out how to to tether
them to a utility function that
that has our own estimation
of what's going to improve our
well-being as its
master you know reward
right so it's like that all that this
this thing can get as intelligent
as it can get but it it only ever really
wants to figure out how to make our
lives better by our own view of better
now not to say there wouldn't be a
conversation about
you know i mean because of all kinds of
things we're not seeing clearly about
what
what is better and and if we were in the
presence of a genie or an oracle
that could really tell us what is better
well then we should we presumably would
want to hear that and we would modify
our sense of of
what to do next in conversation with
these with these uh
minds but i just feel like it is a
failure of imagination
to think that
being in relationship in relationship to
something
more intelligent than yourself isn't in
most cases a circumstance of real
peril because because it is in every
like just to think of think of how
everything on earth
has to if they could think about their
relationship to us if birds could think
about
what we're doing right they would
i mean the bottom line is
they're always in danger of our
discovering that there's something we
care about more than birds
right but there's something we want that
disregards the
the well-being of birds and and you know
obviously
much of our behavior is inscrutable to
them occasionally we pay attention to
them and occasion occasionally we
withdraw our attention
and occasionally we just kill them all
for reasons they can't possibly
understand
but we're if we're building something
more intelligent than ourselves by
definition we're building something
whose horizons of value
and and cognition can
exceed our own and and in ways where we
can't
necessarily foresee again perpetually
that they don't just wake up one day and
decide okay these
these humans need to disappear
so i think i agree with most of the
initial things you said what i don't
necessarily agree with
you my of course nobody knows but that
the more
likely set of trajectories that we're
going to take are going to be
positive that's what i believe in the
sense that
the way you developed i believe the way
you develop
successful ai systems will be
deeply integrated with human society and
for them to succeed
they're going to have to be aligned in
the way we humans are aligned with each
other
which doesn't mean we're aligned there's
no
such thing or i don't see there's such
thing as a perfect alignment
but they're going to be participating in
the dance
in the game theoretic dance of human
society
and as they become more and more
intelligent there could be a point
beyond which we are like birds
to them but what about an intelligence
explosion of some kind so i i believe
the explosion
will be happening but it's
there's a lot of explosion to be done
before we become like birds
i i truly believe that human beings are
very intelligent ways we don't
understand it's not just about chess
it's about
all the intricate computation we're able
to perform
common sense our ability to reason about
this world consciousness
i think we're doing a lot of work we
don't realize it's necessary to be done
in order to
truly become like to truly achieve super
intelligence
and i just think there will be a period
of time that's not overnight
the overnight nature of it will not
literally be overnight
it'll be over a period of decades so my
sense is but why would it be that way
but just take
draw an analogy from recent successes
like something like alpha
go or alpha zero i forget the
the actual metric but it was something
like this algorithm
uh which wasn't even totally it wasn't
bespoke for chess plane
in the matter of i think it was four
hours played itself
so many times and so successfully that
it became the best chess playing
computer
not only was it was not only better than
every human being
it was better than every previous chess
program
in a matter of a day right so like that
like so just imagine
again we don't have to recapitulate
everything about us but just imagine
building
a system uh
and who knows when we'll we'll be able
to do this but at some point we'll be
able
at some point the the 100 100 favorite
things about human cognition
will be analogous to chess in that we
will be able to build machines
that very quickly outperform any human
and then very quickly outperform the
last
algorithm they perform outperform the
humans like something like the alphago
experience seems possible for
facial recognition and detecting human
emotion
and natural language processing right
like well it's it's just
it's it's just the way everyone you know
even math
people math heads tend to have bad
intuitions for exponentiation right we
noticed this during covet i mean you
have some very smart people who
still couldn't get their minds around
the fact that
you know an exponential is is really
surprising i mean things double and
double and double and double again
and you don't notice much of anything
changes and then the last
you know two stages of doubling swamp
everything right and
um it just seems like that to assume
that there isn't a deep analogy between
what we're seeing for the more tractable
the
tractable problems like chess to other
modes of cognition it's like once you
once you crack
that problem it seems because for the
longest time
it was impossible to think we were going
to make headway on
uh in ai you know it's like chess and go
was the goal was seen as yeah
goes seemed unattainable even even when
chess had been cracked
go seemed unattainable yeah as uh
and actually still russell was behind
the people that were saying it's
unattainable
right does it seem like uh you know it's
uh intractable problem
right but there's something different
about the space of
cognition that's detached from human
society which is what chess is
meaning like just thinking having
actual exponential impact on the
physical world is
is different i i tend to believe that
there's
four ai to get to the point where it's
super intelligent
it's going to have to go through the
funnel of society
and for that it has to be deeply
integrated with human beings
and for that it has to be aligned but
you're talking about like actually
hooking us up to like neural link you
know we're not going to be
that's a possibility as well but what i
mean is in order to develop autonomous
weapons systems for example
which are highly concerning to me that
both
u.s and china are participating in now
that
in order to develop them and for them to
become
to have more and more responsibility to
actually do
military military strategic actions
they're going to have to be
integrated into human beings
doing the strategic action they're going
to have to work alongside with each
other
and the way those systems will be
developed will have the natural
safety like switches that are placed on
them
as they develop over time because
they're going to have to convince humans
ultimately they're going to have to
convince humans that this is safer
than humans they're going to you know
eat well self-driving cars is a good
test case right here because like
we're obviously we've made a lot of
progress
and we can imagine
what total progress would look like i
mean it would be amazing and it's
answering
it's cancelling if in the us 40 000
deaths
every year based on ape-driven cars
right so we it's a
excruciating problem that we've all
gotten used to because it was no
alternative but now that we can dimly
see the prospect of an alternative which
if it worked
in a super intelligent fashion yeah
maybe we would go down to zero
highway deaths right or you know
certainly we go down by orders of
magnitude right so maybe we have
you know 400 rather than than 40 000
a year right um
and it's easy to see that there's not
and a missile so obviously this is not
an example of super intelligence this is
narrow intelligence but
the the alignment problem isn't so
obvious there
but there's there are potential
alignment problems there like so like
just
just imagine if some woke team of
engineers
decided that we have to tune the
algorithm
some way i mean there are situations
where the car has to decide who to hit
i mean there's just bad outcomes where
you're going to hit somebody
right now we have a car that can tell
what race you are
right so we're going to build the car to
preferentially hit white people
because white people have had so much
privilege over the years this seems like
the only ethical way to kind of redress
those wrongs of the past
that's something that could get one that
could that could be
get produced as an artifact presumably
of just how you built it and you didn't
even know you engineered it that way
right you you you cause machine learning
yeah you you put some kind of
constraints on it to where it creates
those kinds of objects you basically
built a racist algorithm and you didn't
even intend to or you could intend to
right and it would be aligned with some
people's values but misaligned with
other people's values
but it's like they're interesting
problems
even with something as simple and
obviously good as self-driving cars but
there's a leap that i just think could
be
exact but those are human problems i
just don't think there'll be a leap with
autonomous vehicles
first of all sorry there are
a lot of trajectories which will destroy
human civilization the argument i'm
making it's more likely that we'll take
trajectories that don't
so there i don't think there will be a
leap with autonomous vehicles will all
of a sudden start murdering pedestrians
because once every human on earth is
dead
there will be no more fatalities sort of
unintended consequences of
it's difficult to take that leap i most
systems as we develop and they become
much much more intelligent
in ways that will be incredibly
surprising like stuff that's deep mind
is doing with protein folding
even which is scary to think about and
i'm personally terrified about this
which is the engineering of viruses
using machine learning
the engineering of vaccines using
machine learning right the engineering
of
uh yeah for research purposes pathogens
uh using machine learning like the ways
that can go wrong
i just think that there's always going
to be a closed-loop
supervision of humans before they before
they
become super intelligent not always much
more likely to
to be supervision except of course
the question is how many dumb people are
in the world how many evil people are in
the world
my theory my hope is my
senses that the number of intelligent
people is much higher than the number of
dumb people
that know how to program and the number
of evil people
i think smart people and kind people
over
outnumbered the others except we also we
had a
have to add another group of people
which are just the the smart
and otherwise good but reckless
people right the people who will flip a
switch on
not knowing what's going to happen
they're just kind of hoping
that it's not going to blow up the world
we already know that some of our
smartest people
are those sorts of people you know we
know we've done experiments and this is
something that
martin reeves was whinging about before
the large hadron collider got booted up
i think
we know there are people who are
entertaining experiments or even
performing experiments where there's
some
chance you know not quite infinitesimal
uh that they're going to create a black
hole in the lab and suck every you know
the whole world into it right like that
that's not it's not
you're not a crazy person to worry that
i'll worry about that based on
on the physics and so it was with with
uh
you know the trinity test there were
some people who were still
checking their calculations and they
were off we've we did nuclear tests
where we
were off significantly in terms of the
yield right so it was like
and they still flipped the switch yeah
they still flip the switch and and
sometimes they flip the switch not
to win a world war or to or to save 40
000 lives a year they just
just just to see intellectual curiosity
like this is what i got my grant for
this is this is where i'll get my nobel
prize if if
uh that's in the cards it's on the other
side of this switch
right and um
i mean we again we are we are apes with
egos
who are massively constrained by
self very short-term self-interest even
when we're contemplating
some of the the deepest and most
interesting and most um
universal problems we could ever set our
attention
towards i like just if you read james
watson's book the double helix right
about the the
them you know cracking the the uh the
structure of dna
one thing that's amazing about that book
is just how much of it
almost all of it is being driven
driven by
very apish egocentric
social concerns like that the algorithm
that is producing
this scientific breakthrough is human
competition
if you're james watson it's like i'm
going to get there before linus pauling
and you know it's just it's
so much of his bandwidth is captured by
that right now that
you know that's that becomes
that becomes more and more of a
liability when you're talking about
producing technology that can change
everything in an instant you know
you're talking about not only
understanding
you know we're just at a different
moment in human history we're not
when we're doing research
on viruses we're now doing the kind of
research
that can cause someone somewhere else to
be able to
to make that virus or weaponize that
virus or
or um it's just uh
i don't know i mean our power is our
wisdom is
it it does not seem like our wisdom is
scaling with our power
right and like that that seems like in
so far and with is
as wisdom and power become unaligned
i get more and more concerned
you